o
Olá eu sou o Sir e eu vou explicar para
vocês como a colaboração entre pessoas
Inteligência Artificial vai nos ajudar
ao próximo passo próximo salto na
criatividade e na inovação só para fazer
isso eu vou contar mostrar o pessoal
para vocês como que nasceu minha
primeira filha ela começou a fazer o
sonzinho dela com quem quer falar Eu fiz
uma aposta com minha esposa eu postei
com a ANAC a primeira palavra dela ia
ser papai minha esposa Foi ridículo e
aceitou na hora não que ela aceitou
comecei a trabalhar
Quem me dera repetição papai papai papai
papai E se fosse Positivo sem que ela
fizesse um sonzinho que fosse parecido
com o papai ganhar um beijo um abraço um
sorriso o meu outro quem me aposta
primeira palavra minha filha foi papai
esposa ficou super brava não usou
derrubar eu peço uma perdedora
é só que um problema a minha filhinha
Fala papai para tudo olhar para mim
papai a minha esposa papai para minha
sogra para pai televisão papai brinquedo
do papai papai papai papai que aconteceu
ela aprendeu a reproduzir o som papai
mas eu não entendeu porque ela tava
falando Papai Para que serve um papai
qualquer relação entre o papai a mamãe e
por que que a mamãe tá brava com o papai
ela só aprendeu a fazer aquele som eu
acho que depois de um tempo ela começou
a aprender o porquê das coisas a criar
uma relação entre causa e efeito
resposta não se inteligência
e
essa inteligência né a gente não sabe
direito o que é inteligência a gente não
sabe direito o que é o estado consciente
que a gente não existe algumas teorias
não existe um consenso muito grande
sobre isso uma dessas teorias diz que na
nossa cabeça nós temos como se fossem
mapas do mundo as desenhamos um atlas do
mundo conforme a gente vai aprendendo
sobre ele Ele fica o tempo todo fazendo
previsões sobre o que aconteceria se a
gente Navegar sem nesses mapas então eu
vou pegar um copo na minha cabeça deve
ter um mapa do que quer um copo e eu
faço previsões o que acontece dependendo
da força aquela parte desse copo muita
força o quebre o copo a macho coloco um
pouco a força deixa ele cair e nessas
previsões que a gente tem uma relação
com inteligência artificial eu posso boa
parte da minha carreira trabalhando com
previsões usando estatística para fazer
previsões O João quer um pouco maior
chamado de aprendizado de máquina
tem um subconjunto da Inteligência
Artificial e o que que é inteligência
artificial
Inteligência Artificial é um jeito
diferente de você programar um
computador através de exemplos
e para realizar tarefas que mostra
consideramos como inteligente vamos lá
fica uma tarefa que nós consigamos uma
inteligente
escrever falar que conhecer pessoas
objetos e o que é uma programação por
exemplos o gerar lucro quer um programa
para reconhecer gatos em fotografias
esse aqui é um problema gigante escrever
um gato como é que eu ele é um gato como
é que eu fosse um gato como é que o
bigode do gato cor de pelo tamanho e por
aí vai ter só um problema gigante super
trabalhoso ele só ia servir para
encontrar gatos em fotografias o
programa um computador por exemplo
significa ter um modelo um milhar onde
eu coloco várias fotografias do que a
de coisas que não são gato esse modelo
vai transformar esse fotografias em
números Vai Multiplicar esses números lá
dentro até ele conseguir dar uma
resposta uma previsão para mim essa
fotografia de um gato é só fotografia
não é de um gato quanto mais fotografias
eu coloco melhor fica esse modelo melhor
fica essa previsão funcionar contexto
também
imagina que eu quero treinar um modelo
ensinar uma máquina aprender a próxima
palavra de um texto após protesto de
vários lugares a internet blog site
Wikipedia livros e treinar esse modelo
aprender a próxima palavra depois depois
de uma sentença vou pegar música do
Toquinho
em uma folha qualquer eu desenho um sol
e eu pergunto pelo computador Qual é a
próxima palavra ele vai olhar para isso
vai ver folha desenho
som ao passar próximo a palavra também
sempre vejo Amarelo
foi gente não tem um desenho quente pode
ser
e essa previsão começar a ficar tão boas
mas tão boas que a próximo passo disso é
se você pode prever Qual que é a próxima
palavra só que você prever a próxima a
próxima e a próxima escrever um texto
sozinho usando esse ar
ah ah
sim você consegue Essa música é muito
boa talvez você não consiga completar a
música e com cinco ou seis retas é fácil
fazer um castelo Mas alguma coisa ou vai
ser escrita pela máquina que vai fazer
sentido com a frase original e esse
sentindo que é feito com a frase
original EA por causa desse nesse
sentido a Microsoft fez um experimento a
gente criar um bot no Twitter queria
tentar a personalidade de um adolescente
ia conversar com pessoas sobre assuntos
gerais na internet
esse bote não durou um dia demorou um
dia menos um dia para mais pessoas
dentro baixo experimento ele escreveu
algumas dezenas de milhares de mensagens
para pessoas na internet
o e uma parte desse conteúdo foi
ofensivo
porque é
as duas vezes que minha filha não
entendeu porque ela tava fazendo um
sonzinho o papai papai papai essa
tecnologia a um sabe porque que ela tá
escrevendo uma coisa não sabe por quê
que ela tá respondendo essas perguntas
eu não sabe se vai ou não ofender uma
pessoa mesmo que uma pessoa como diria
minha mãe não tem juízo
Oi e essa falta de juízo é uma
alimentação
o Master aqui essa militar são por causa
dessa limitação não tem valor da
Inteligência Artificial mas pelo
contrário tem algumas empresas e pessoas
que estão usando essa relação pessoa vir
e a para criar produtos fantásticos que
eu dar uns exemplos pra vocês
e tem um grupo de comédia de improviso
chamado in Probox é e como é de
improviso aquele tipo de comédia um dos
comediantes pegam do público na hora um
tema em um cenário
e eles improviso objetivo é Seria
engraçado onde carregado da comédia de
improviso que você não pode falar não
é só que eles colocam computador no copo
com ele e o computador vai passar por os
comediantes no ponto frases para que
estes comediantes Interprete a frase
entendo como é que ela vai se encaixar
no todo e de emoção nessa frase para
poder criar fazer uma colaboração entre
eles só computador não está limitado a
escrever texto para os comediantes ele
também pode pegar essa cena esse objeto
e criar um cenário Então você tem os
comediantes no palco fazendo a comédia
deles e você tem muita lam em cima deles
o cenário com os comediantes sobre
Apóstolos eles vão só conseguiram criar
uma comédia onde tenho essa relação
entre pessoa e máquina mas isso me dar
mais uma de mim são nessa comédia
tem outro grupo de pesquisadores que
perceberam que esses modelos são tão
bons para entender a língua inglesa
e tocaram palavras o pediram para ir lá
trocar a palavras que tem uma um jeito
de escrever Aparecido uma sonoridade
parecida Eles criaram uma máquina de
trocadilhos eu acho que na comédia você
tem bastante margem para errar tem
bastante margem para tentar coisas novas
Afinal até um trocadilho quando ele é
ruim às vezes é bom
mas tantas empresas estão criando coisas
bem legais com Essas tecnologias por
exemplo
e também xylaria na Suécia e fazendo
isso aqui que eles criaram olhar para
prever a qualidade de Whisky baseado na
receita
e o que que esse essa aí a faz ele pega
a receita do Whisky modo de preparo e
ingredientes e por aí vai ele prevecist
vai ser bom não entrou no Seminário
Teológico e falar não tá bom se você
criar uma receita completamente nova de
Whisky que tem uma grande chance de ter
uma nota alta with High escrever uma
receita eu acho que fazer whisky o
negócio trabalhoso e dá um jeito de
pegar essa receita ele vai produzir o
whiskey quando ele ficou pronto ele não
só esgotou rápido mas talvez por
questões de ser uma novidade mas a nota
desse Whisky foi um mais alta do que a
nota dos produtos dessa dessa empresa
então visão só olharam só consigo criar
um disco novo do zero mas ele conseguiu
criar um pequeno melhor do que ele já
tinha antes
o que muita empresa no Chile que eles
fazem produtos substitutos de carne
leite e ovos
a cuia deles os a composição química de
plantas o substituto são feitos com
plantas Eu uso a composição química
desses desses produtos dessas plantas
para imitar o sabor e textura eles
querem dar para você o mesmo sabor de
uma carne e a mesma sensação de comer
uma carne usando só produtos naturais e
lógico já vai escrever a receita no
laboratório eles vão ter que aperfeiçoar
essa receita aí alguém vai ter que
cozinhar então trabalho muito
colaborativo Entre esses três grupos
e as mais legal é que ele tem uma
maionese e essa maionese deles no Chile
já é uma das maiores das marcas que mais
vende no mercado fez um só conseguir
criar um produto que os cães adoram que
os crentes são apaixonados mas eles
utilizam menos energia e menos água na
produção desses produtos o que é ótimo
para resolver os grandes problemas da
humanidade o meio ambiente agradece
E por falar em grandes problemas
é o tipo mais do que uma empresa do
Google criou um olhar capaz de prever
estrutura de proteínas e estrutura de
proteína é super importante para
o desenvolvimento de medicamentos e
tratamentos presente algumas empresas
que estão usando a para acelerar o
processo de descoberta de medicamentos
então a gente que legal no futuro se a
gente for capaz de dividir pela metade o
tempo que leva para você botar um
remédio novo no mercado quantas vidas
que eu não consegui salvar com isso é
só para concluir
existisse uma alimentação uma diferença
bem grande entrar Nossa inteligência
entre artificial Será que um dia a gente
vai conseguir criar uma máquina tão ou
mais inteligente do que nosso
eu não sei hum não sei mesmo mas essa
nenhuma pergunta tão boa uma pergunta
muito melhor né como é que eu faço para
criar um produto que os meus clientes
vão ficar apaixonados por ele e resolver
os grandes problemas da humanidade
bom falar de Meio Ambiente a gente muito
inovação mas muito inovação mesmo e
talvez a solução para isso seja uma
colaboração última hora entra a
inteligência a nossa inteligência
artificial
bom obrigado